did you know creatine is not just a
sports supplement but a naturally
occurring compound found in Meat and
Fish and it is also produced by our body
in the liver kidneys and pancreas so
right now at this very moment your body
is making creatine which you didn't even
know about you've probably heard a lot
about this magical powder that promises
incredible gains and hulk-like strength
but what's the real story what is this
thing called creatine and why is it
getting so popular among Gym and Fitness
enthusiasts
most people take creatine without really
understanding how creatine acts in our
body hello and welcome to Med simplified
I'm Dr Umar Malik and in this video we
are going to talk about the science of
creatine metabolism we'll understand
what is creatine and how it acts in our
body we'll talk about how creatine
increases our muscle energy levels and
endurance and then in the end we'll also
talk about how creatine leads to muscle
growth and hypertrophy so make sure to
watch the video till the very end so
let's first try to understand what is
creatine and how it increases our muscle
strength and energy levels so creatine
is a naturally occurring compound that
is produced by our body and we also get
creatine through some food substances
like Meat and Fish whenever we consume
Creatine or whenever our body produces
it naturally it is first converted into
phosphocreatine which is then stored in
our muscles now phoso creatine is
basically a high energy molecule that
acts as a reserve of energy and that is
rapidly utilized during intense physical
activities such as weight lifting or
sprinting
to understand the science behind
creatine metabolism you have to first
understand how our muscles use energy in
the first place let me simplify this for
you
the chief molecule that is used by
ourselves for energy is ATP short for
adenosine triphosphate ATP is also known
as the energy currency of the cells
because ATP is like a tiny battery that
our cells use to power different
activities including muscle contractions
let's first try to understand in a very
simple way what is ATP
ATP is a molecule that is made of three
different parts the central piece is
known as ribose which is basically a
five carbon sugar on one side of ribose
is attached adenine and on the other
side we have the most important
component of ATP the phosphate groups
one molecule of ATP contains three
phosphate groups hence the name
adenosine triphosphate the energy of ATP
is stored in the bonds between these
phosphate groups the third phosphate
group is on the end and has the most
energy when our cells need energy ATP
breaks apart by losing the third
phosphate group this release of the
phosphate group gives off a lot of
energy that our cells can use
after losing the phosphate group ATP
becomes ADP or adenosine diphosphate die
meaning 2 as it is left with only two
phosphate groups
think of ATP like a rechargeable battery
it's starts with three phosphate groups
full of energy when it's used up one
phosphate group is taken away and it
becomes ADP
but don't worry the ADB can be recharged
back into ATP by adding that missing
phosphate group again
now there are three main mechanisms by
which ADP is converted to ATP again
first we have oxidative phosphorylation
that takes place in the part of the cell
known as mitochondria mitochondria are
basically the energy factories of our
cell and here oxygen is used to produce
ATP this is the most efficient pathway
for ATP production and generates a large
amount of ATP
the second mechanism of producing ATP is
glycolysis glycolysis basically means
breakdown of glucose and this process
doesn't require oxygen but this process
produces only a small amount of ATP the
third mechanism is the one that we are
interested in and it is none other than
the phospho-creatine system
phosphogridine is a high energy molecule
stored in the muscles and like we
discussed it is basically the active
form of creatine in our body it acts as
a reserve for Rapid ATP regeneration
let's look at how phosphocreatine helps
in regenerating ATP in our muscles
our cells have a very limited amount of
ATP available which get depleted after a
couple of seconds of high intensity
activity this is where the
phospho-creatine system comes into play
phospho creatine is basically a creatine
molecule with which a high energy
phosphate group is attached like we
discussed earlier when an ATP is broken
down it loses its one phosphate group
and is converted to ADP
phosphocreatine donates its phosphate
group to the ADP and converts it back to
ATP
during high intensity exercises such as
heavy weight lifting or intense bursts
of activity the demand for energy is
immediate and significant the fossil
creatine system provides a rapid and
readily available source of high energy
phosphate groups to regenerate ATP to
meet this demand the first two methods
of ATP regeneration the oxidative
phosphorylation and glycolysis are slow
and take time to regenerate ATP so they
are not so efficient in high intensity
exercises like lifting heavy weights the
phospho-creatine process replenishes the
ATP stores quickly allowing our muscles
to maintain their strength and power for
extended periods it means that with more
creatine available in our muscles we can
perform high intensity exercises
slightly longer before getting fatigued
so to summarize by increasing the levels
of phosphocreatine in our muscles
creatine supplementation enhances the
availability of atps in our muscle cells
which improves the overall performance
in activities which require short bursts
of energy this translates to better
performance in sports and activities
that require a lot of energy like weight
lifting sprinting or high intensity
interval training so this was all about
how creatine increases our muscle
endurance and energy levels now let's
try to understand how creatine leads to
muscle growth and hypertrophy so
creatine is associated with muscle
hypertrophy as it increases the level of
protein synthesis in our muscle cells
now there are several mechanisms by how
creatine improves the overall protein
synthesis in our muscles but the three
main ones include enhanced ATP levels in
our muscles enhanced cell hydration and
improved levels of anabolic hormones in
our muscles let's have a brief look at
each one of them as we discussed
previously creatine supplementation
increases the availability of atps in
our muscle cells these atps apart from
their use in muscle contraction also
provide energy for production of new
proteins protein synthesis requires a
lot of energy by increasing ATP
availability creatine supplement
commentation supports these ATP
dependent processes and increases the
rate of routine synthesis
creatine also increases cellular
hydration through its osmotic function
attracting water into the muscle cells
and makes them hold more water inside
this extra hydration creates a good
environment for building new proteins
when muscle cells are well hydrated
proteins can be made more efficiently
the process of making proteins requires
specific enzymes and with enough water
these enzymes can work at their best
Additionally the water also helps to
carry nutrients like amino acids into
the cells which are needed to build
proteins another important way how
creatine increases muscle growth is by
increasing the release of anabolic
hormones in the body such as igf-1
igf-1 is short for insulin-like growth
factor 1 which is the hormone released
by our liver it resembles insulin in
structure and it has potent effects on
promoting protein synthesis enhancing
muscle hypertrophy and inhibiting muscle
protein breakdown
while the exact mechanisms are not fully
understood it is believed that creatine
supplementation stimulates the liver to
produce more igf-1
so by increasing the production of new
proteins by various mechanisms that we
just discussed creatine supplementation
contributes to improved muscle
adaptation increased muscle mass and
enhanced recovery from exercise induced
damage in conclusion the science behind
creatine is fascinating this naturally
occurring compound offers tremendous
benefits for athletes and fitness
enthusiasts alike
by increasing ATP levels promoting
protein synthesis enhancing cell
hydration and stimulating the release of
anabolic hormones creatine
supplementation can help you achieve
your muscle growth and performance goals
it's no wonder why creatine has become a
popular supplement in the fitness world
however keep in mind that individual
responses may vary and it's important to
listen to your body and follow
recommended dosages with proper guidance
and a well-rounded approach to Fitness
creatine can be a valuable tool in your
journey towards a stronger fitter and
healthier you in our upcoming videos we
are going to talk about the science
behind some of the common side effects
related to creatine supplementation so
to get notified about that video make
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
also hit that Bell icon if you found
this video helpful I humbly request you
to support our channel on patreon.com
matchimplified we typically don't work
with sponsors but making such videos
requires a lot of research writing
scripting and animation which all cost
us money so you can support us by making
a small donation on our patreon page
thank you so much for watching this
video and until next time stay healthy
and stay curious